ich war früher immer so müde ich
brauchte mindestens 9 Stunden schlafen
Nacht und ich war gar nicht Energie
geladen und das alles weil ich eine
Schildrüsenunterfunktion habe und das
haben so viele Menschen man fühlt sich
dann halt auch einfach gar nicht fit und
will einfach irgendwie immer nur
schlafen dann habe ich aber vor 5 Jahren
angefangen Schwarzkümmelöl einzunehmen
eigentlich auch nur erstmal so mal
schauen was passiert und dann habe ich
irgendwann gemerkt ey mir geht's immer
besser ich schlafe besser ich brauche
nicht mehr so viel schlaf ich komme
mittlerweile auch mit 6 Stunden Schlaf
klar und mein letzter mit tagschlaf ist
glaube ich 5 Jahre her ich mache so dass
ich einfach vom Schlafen gehen hier mit
diesem Ausgießer direkt zir ein
Esslöffel nehme einfach nach Gefühl also
so lecker lecker also man muss sich
daran gewöhnen aber es hat so viele
benefits und ich bin nur durch das
Schwarzkümmelöl von 100 Mikrogramm auf
25 Mikrogramm runtergegangen und habe
gar keine Symptome mehr